ich habe ein wenig gänsehaut wenn das
stimmt was der fokus jetzt gemeldet hat
dann stehen wir in der energieerzeugung
vor einer revolution mit dem kernreaktor
führt zu hause hätten wir energie ohne
ende was es damit auf sich hat jetzt den
klicks und science und fiction wird das
wirklichkeit dann braucht die menschheit
schon bald kein benzin gas keine
kernspaltung kohle windkraft und so
weiter mehr immer mehr meldungen
sprechen dafür dass die kalte fusion
gelungen ist dh die kernfusion bei
niedrigen temperaturen würde
funktionieren schon einmal 1989 gegen
die meldung um die welt dass diese
revolution gelungen sei martin
fleischmann und stanley pons zwei
chemiker an der university of utah
behaupteten dass ihnen diese kalte
fusion geglückt sei doch weltweit konnte
niemand das experiment wiederholen aber
hat es tatsächlich nicht funktioniert
oder wurde hier bewusst boykottiert
waren die physiker weltweit sauer dass
zwei her gelaufene chemiker ihnen den
rang abgelaufen hatten das erinnert mich
an die schwierige zulassung des hafens
des sogenannten wunder open niemand
wollte glauben dass seine abgase nur 30
grad heiß werden
der tüv hannover versuchte wissentlich
mit falschen messungen die einführung
dieses heizkessels zu verhindern
heute ist er als brennwertkessel
standard in nahezu jedem haushalt und
hat die umweltverschmutzung mit schwefel
um rund 90 prozent reduziert und den
energieverbrauch um rund die hälfte
verringert danke an den tüv und
zahlreiche behörden dass sie die
einführung dieser umweltfreundlichen
technik jahrelang aufgehalten haben bei
der kalten kernfusion könnte es nun
ähnlich sein
die forschungen an der heißen fusion
wären überflüssig milliarden-programme
während von einem auf den anderen tag
sinnlos die heiße fusion fordert nämlich
einen ungeheuren aufwand in einem
reaktor muss dazu ein wasserstoff plasma
auf eine temperatur von 100 millionen
grad erhitzt werden dort zündet dann die
kernfusion die neutronen frei setzt sie
stoßen im mantel des reaktors atomkerne
an was wärmeenergie erzeugt die dann
abgeführt wird hier auf der erde muss
also ein zustand wie auf der sonne
erzeugt werden was technisch das
aufwendigste verfahren ist dass die
menschheit je realisiert hat allein der
in traktor der gerade in südfrankreich
gebaut wird kostet mehr als 50
milliarden euro
bei der kalten kernfusion wäre dieser
aufwand überflüssig hier würde die
fusion bei auf der erde üblichen
temperaturen von bis zu einigen hundert
grad celsius stattfinden
doch in der wissenschaftlichen forschung
will davon niemand etwas wissen mit den
geltenden naturgesetzen sei das nicht
vereinbar ist zum beispiel aus dem
max-planck-institut für plasmaphysik in
garching zu hören
nur scheint das kaum noch mit der
realität vereinbart
es werden nämlich bereits patente für
die kalte fusion erteilt und selbst die
nasa ist inzwischen davon überzeugt dass
wir häuser mit kleinen reaktoren heizen
und fahrzeuge und flugzeuge damit
antreiben können
dabei sind die veröffentlichung zur
kalten fusion zum teil etwas mysteriös
da werden etwas unordentliche labor
gezeigt videos sind plötzlich privat und
bei den verschiedenen verfahren werden
zum teil geheime rezepturen verwendet
ist also doch alles nur humbug
auf jeden fall trauen sich nur wenige
journalisten artikel zum thema zu
veröffentlichen
auch in deutschland waren es bisher nur
wenige einer von ihnen ist michael
odenwald vom focus und auch renommierte
wissenschaftler haben inzwischen
bestätigt dass in reaktoren in denen
eine kalte fusion abläuft mehr energie
erzeugt wird als mit den üblichen
chemischen prozessen erklärbar wäre die
konsequenzen dieser technik wären
dramatisch auf der erde
gäbe es genügend brennstoff für solche
reaktoren wie zum beispiel deuterium ein
wasserstoff isotop die strahlung solcher
reaktoren ist sehr schwach und einfach
abzuschirmen und es entsteht keine
kettenreaktion solche reaktoren können
wie fukushima explodieren man könnte sie
einfach in den eigenen keller stellen
mit dieser technik hätten wir energie
ohne ende und wir müssten die umwelt
weder radioaktiv noch mit co2 verseuchen
es würde unsere welt dramatisch
verändern
was meint ihr streben wir einer goldenen
zukunft entgegen wer hat recht
wissenschaftler oder die entwickler der
kalten fusion wird es schon bald die
ersten fusionsreaktoren für zuhause
geben diskutiertes in den kommentaren
wenn ihr artikel oder meldungen zum
thema kalte fusion findet schreibt sie
in die kommentare ich poste sie in
klicks und blog hier geht es zum was
geht ab wie du zum gleichen thema kalte
fusion und hier zum letzten klick zum
video die chemie der liebe und den link
zum blog findet ihr wie immer oben links
oder in der video beschreibung was
bleibt mir jetzt noch bis dann bleibt
dran zu sagen